تتطلب الرياضة الأجنبية
[الموسيقى]
[ضحك]
في بلدنا الكثير من
الاستثمار وبدون
أن تستثمر بعض تلك الشركات ، فمن
الصعب جدًا توفير التسهيلات
التي
نحتاجها وأعتقد أنه مع أي شيء بالطبع
نحن على دراية به في بلدنا
السمنة
والصحة ولكن كل شيء يمكن القيام به
باعتدال وأعتقد أن أي شيء
تشارك فيه أو
تشاركه باعتدال نادرًا ما يكون مشكلة
لذلك أنا أفهم المخاوف التي لدى الناس
ومن الواضح أن الرجلين كان لهما
أساس منطقي مختلف للاثنين  المواقف التي
اتخذوها ولكن هل تعلم أن هناك
دائمًا صورة أكبر لهذه الأشياء
أعتقد أنه
من وجهة نظري
أتفق تمامًا وأعتقد أنه من الواضح أن الرعاة
يحق لهم
الحصول على ما يريدون إذا أه
إذا دفعوا
من الواضح أن المال للقيام بذلك ، نعم ،
هذا ليس شيئًا
شخصيًا ، لقد فكرت كثيرًا فيه ، من
الواضح أنني رأيت ذلك يتجول
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وأشياء من هذا القبيل ، لكن
إذا كنت صبورًا تمامًا  أنا أركز
على الغد
أكثر من أي شيء من هذا القبيل